I know myself that the more I study
Islam the more I look at the evidences
improves it makes me a better human
being
helps me to be more merciful and loving
because this is what islam teaches to be
loving and kind with all of mankind so
now when you get to know islam you truly
get to know it yes there are atrocities
that are committed and we condemn these
things on both sides but we as muslims
need to be at a higher level at a higher
standard as the creator tells us in the
verbatim word of god the koran to repel
evil with what is better not worse and
God Almighty has sent the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him as the last
and final messenger who was a brother to
Jesus and Moses they all brought the
same message worship the Creator not to
Croatia do good deeds and we fear doing
any injustice to a human being to even
an animal
so now innocent people that go over to
Syria they go over to help
journalists aid workers a Muslim no
Muslim in his right mind who knows Islam
can even think about beheading or
killing an innocent person because this
is clear if the Prophet Muhammad Allah
calls of God calls him as a mercy to the
world he was sent as a mercy to the
world and God Almighty tells us that he
will not have mercy on those who do not
have mercy to the his creatures on earth
so just as Islam helps me to be more
loving and kind and merciful and I fear
doing any harm to any human being
unjustly so do over 1.7 billion Muslims
all over the world who live a religion
of peace and mercy and justice so Islam
is free of this free of terrorism and
all these other crazy barbaric things
that our people are trying to associate
with it and we wish that the media would
give the microphone to people who have
condemned these things give the
spotlight to the good that Muslims are
doing but it's shamefully they want to
focus on the 0.111 small fringe elements
nothing to do with Islam Islam says love
all mankind that's why we're sharing
this message because we want the best
for you and we want the best for all
mankind we'll see you next time
God willing on the Deen show continue to
tune in peace be on to you please
subscribe to the Biggio follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below